-Mikey!
Thank you for being here.
Your new show "Is It Cake?"
is incredible. I love it.
-That means a lot, man.
Thanks for watching.
-I'm like, is it cake
or isn't it?
I mean, the one with the burger
really got me, by the way.
Uh -- oh.
Do you have a twin brother?
-No, that's the cake version
of me.
[ Piano key strikes ]
The bakers we have on the show
are really talented.
You want to taste it?
-Y-You want me to eat
the cake version of you?
-Yeah. It's delicious.
His skin is
cream cheese frosting.
[ Metal scrapes ]
-Hey! What are you doing, man?
I'm not cake! He is!
[ Dramatic sting ]
-No, he's lying.
I'm the real Mikey Day.
-No, I am!
-I am!
-Jimmy, eat him.
He tastes so good.
-No, eat him!
He's absolutely delectable!
-How are you both talking
if one of you is cake?
-The bakers are really,
really talented.
-Right? So talented.
-Just so, so talented.
-Alright, alright!
Enough! Enough!
I just gotta go for it.
[ Squish ]
-Why would you do this?!
I'm a guest on your show,
you monster!
-Mikey, I'm so sorry!
I-I-- What have I done?!
-Nah, I'm kidding.
I'm cake.
[ Chuckles ]
Mmm!